- It doesn't matter.
Nothing matters.
- [Diane] Wow, what happened in Malibu?
- I got to go.
- So, I think a big turning point
for our show happens in that first season,
at, really, episode
seven and episode eight,
which are called Say
Anything, and The Telescope.
Funnily enough, we only
sent the first six episodes
to critics, which looking back,
might have been a mistake,
because I think they were
some of the first audience
who didn't really get
what we were going for,
because, maybe we didn't tell them.
Maybe, we kept it a little
too close to the vest
that right around the corner,
there were these two big episodes
that kind of changed the whole thing.
And so, Say Anything is episode seven,
and that's an episode that's entirely told
from Princess Carolyn's perspective,
up to that moment,
everything, almost everything
that's happened in the show
has been through Bojack.
A few episodes had small
B-stories or C-stories,
but they're really heavy A-story episodes.
And then, you kind of switch it,
and be like, "No, Bojack is
the side story this time.
"It's really focused on
this other character."
It felt like a bit of a departure for us,
and we wanted to kind of explore
what is the damage that Bojack causes
because when he is your central character,
you're with him, you know,
he kind of falls into
some sort of wreckage
and kind of, steps out and
like, dusts himself off,
and wanders into the next misadventure,
but we wanted it through Princess Carolyn,
explore what is it like
being another person
in this person's life.
What is it like attaching
yourself to this kind of toxicity?
And that episode, Say Anything,
has the first really sad
ending of the series,
that everything up until
then had been pretty light,
or maybe we'd end on
like a dark kind of joke,
but Say Anything really
ends on like, a serious kind
of sad moment with this lonely character.
And that for me was a real sign
of where we wanted to go.
And the next episode, The Telescope,
I think, kind of, pushes
that into overdrive.
That's the episode where Bojack goes
to visit his old friend, Herb,
and it's kind of set up
as this special episode
where Bojack's gonna make
amends with this guy,
and he doesn't, and Herb
refuses to forgive him
for this thing that
happened in their past,
and kind of, because of our expectations
from watching television,
and because of Bojack's own expectations,
you know, learning most
of what he's learned
through making television,
he really expects, at the
end, this is gonna work out,
and it really doesn't,
and that also is a sign to our audience
that we're telling our stories
a little differently here,
and we're doing things
a little differently.
(feet thumping)
I like to lean into the gimmick.
I like to say, "Okay, well, let's do it."
And then, what does that mean?
And what does this story
that would necessitate
that kind of storytelling?
Because I think the form should
always match the function.
I think you want to have
a format for a story
that goes hand-in-hand with
this story you're telling,
but it doesn't necessarily mean,
you need to have the story first,
and then, come up with the format.
A lot of times, you can
start with the format.
You can start with, "Let's tell an episode
"without any dialogue."
And so, that episode,
specifically, Fish Out of Water,
you know, I came into the writer's room,
and I said, "I want to do a story
"where none of the characters talked."
And that was a challenge for the meeting
'cause like, how do you justify that?
That was the first challenge
because you didn't want to just be like,
"Oh, we're in Charlie Chaplin land,
"you know, for no reason."
And that, characters are
just kind of like looking
at each other and Mister Bean-ing it up
when it's these characters
that we've known
for three seasons to have
full auditory functionality.
So, you need something
to kind of, explains
why the characters wouldn't be talking.
Kind of separately to that,
Mike Hollingsworth is
our supervising director,
and he'd been campaigning
me to do an underwater story
because at the end of season two,
we had an episode with a boat,
which is like a throwaway scene.
There's a boat on the dock,
and you see like, a gangplank of people
from the dock walking into the boat.
And there's another gangplank
going off into the ocean,
and you see all these fish
walking up the gangplank
into the boat.
So that like, eluded
to something going on,
underneath the water,
and so, Mike was really fastened
and I'm like, "What's
happening in underwater world?
"Let's tell a story about that."
And then, also, provided
some complexity to me
because I didn't understand
how you could tell a story
underwater with our characters,
who were all air-breathing,
land-dwelling mammals, right?
How do you tell a story underwater
with our characters who
don't live underwater?
And then, how would they even
communicate to each other?
I remember one night, waking
up in the middle of the night,
and I realized, "Eureka!
"These questions answer each other."
On the one hand, how do
you tell a silent story?
How do you justify it?
How do you tell an underwater story?
Put the peanut butter in the chocolate,
and together it makes Fish Out of Water.
So then, the room tried to
figure out how to do it,
and that episode was written
by Jordan Young and Elijah
Aaron, two brilliant writers,
and I said, "How do you
write an episode like that?"
And they said, "We don't
know, let's figure it out."
So, we talked through the story,
and we, you know, kind of
put it up on the whiteboard
like you do any other episode,
and then, when it was time to write it,
they wrote the whole episode,
just without the dialogue,
just, you know, stage directions.
Bojack, you know, walks
through the rooms of the hotel.
He looks out.
He sees a bunch of sardines
cram themselves into a room,
you know, all these joke,
but just written out,
but they didn't know how
long to make the script
because you have certain benchmarks.
You have an understanding
of like, how many words per minute?
You know, three seasons
in, you kind of get a sense
of how long a script should be,
but we didn't know the timing
for how long the script is.
They just wrote a script.
We sent it to Mike Hollingsworth,
our supervising director,
who end up directing that episode.
And then, he timed it out by acting it.
He read through it and
kind of, did the motions,
and timed himself, thinking
how long is this gonna take.
And so, we ended up getting it to time,
based on Mike's estimates.
- Hello, you're always,
Why don't you go outside
and play or something?
- Bye, mom.
- You are fired.
Goodbye, thank you.
- Time's Arrow, in season four,
is also a big benchmark episode.
I think, part of it was
structurally looking at the season,
and up until that point,
every episode eleven had been kind
of a big bravura episode for us.
I mean, the first season,
it was a crazy drug trip,
and the second season, it was
this sojourn into New Mexico,
and the third season, it
was a very tragic drug binge
that had really been the
climax for the season.
And in all of those episodes,
they're mostly about
Bojack behaving terribly
and ruining things,
and it felt like four seasons in,
we can't go to that well again.
We have to think of like
a new way to tell a story
that still feels like a
climax for the season,
but isn't just about
Bojack being a schmuck.
And so, part of the idea was,
"Well, can we reverse that a little bit?
"Can we give Bojack a
bit of a hero moment?"
Which the end of the episode
does actually provide,
and is a very cathartic
climax for the season.
In kind of an opposite way
of how most of our seasons operate.
And then, we were talking
about this character
of Beatrice, Bojack's mother,
who the whole season is
suffering from dementia,
and we thought, "Wouldn't it be cool
"to tell a story from her point of view?"
And see the world as she sees it
and is experiencing it,
and that a lot of the
kind of non-sequiturs
that, maybe, she's been motioning
to throughout the season,
we get further context for 'em.
We'd see her story and her life.
And I think a big theme of the show
is that nobody is just
a hero or a villain,
that all of us are complex,
flawed individuals.
And so, to paint a picture of Beatrice,
who up until this point,
had been pretty terrifying,
and awful, and painted as
solely a burden to Bojack
in the present,
and a scarring influence
on him in the past,
but they try to draw her sympathetically,
and make people care about her.
That felt like a really
fun, interesting challenge.
So, that's kind of the
beginning of that episode.
I think, meanwhile, that episode
was written by Kate Purdy,
who had written on our
show since season one,
is a brilliant writer,
and at that point, Kate and I
were developing this new show,
"Undone," for Amazon, which
plays a lot with time,
and people falling through time,
and unsure of where they
are and what they are.
So, in some ways,
Time's Arrow was kind of
a test run for "Undone."
It was like, "Let's play around with this.
"Like, will this be too difficult
"for our audience to follow?
"Can we jump around in time in this way,
"you know, through this perspective
"without really explaining
it as it's going?"
And it was very encouraging.
I think the test was successful,
and made us want to explore
more with our other show.
- The only thing that
matters is right now,
this moment, this one spectacular moment
we are sharing together, right Sarah Lynn?
Sarah Lynn?
- One of the tenets of the show, to me,
was that it was not a
typical animated show
that snaps back to status quo at the end
of every episode.
I remember having a meeting very early on
with some of the designers,
and the directors,
and talking about the look of the show,
and the feel of it,
and I remember saying that, you know,
if Bojack has like a big
party in episode three,
and all the furniture gets screwed up,
in episode four, the furniture
should still be screwed up.
That, you know, kind
of, we're used to shows
that just kind of, it ends,
and the next episode,
everything's back to normal,
and I want that damage to linger.
And that kind of became a
metaphor for the show itself,
and the emotional toll that
the events of the show take
on the characters, and then,
I want you to, kind of, feel
over the course of that first season,
and then, in the subsequent seasons,
that the damage that has
happened to this character
and to his relationships have had weight,
and have had effect,
and that if someone gets in
a big fight in one episode,
it's not gonna go back to
normal the next episode.
He's still thinking about all the stuff
that's happened to him,
and the things that he's done,
even if he's not mentioning it, right?
He's not necessarily saying,
"Oh, I still feel guilty
"over that thing I did four episodes ago,"
but we know it's still in there,
and occasionally, there are reminders,
where things will bubble back up
or think about all the history
that's happened to him.
And so, I think a big part of that idea
or what goes hand-in-hand with that idea
of that the damage lingers
is that people will die,
and that when people die, they are dead,
and they're not coming back.
And so, it felt important
to tell that story.
We've actually told it a
few times on this show now,
but we wanted,
we wanted to do it.
(laughs) We wanted to play out
the effects of these actions
as we kind of put it into place,
especially when you talk
about the end of season three,
it felt like we've been
setting up these dominoes
for awhile, like really, since, you know,
I'd say the third episode of season one.
And so, by this point, you
know, we got to knock them over
or what are we doing?
- Are we judging you as the best booty?
- Whoa, Bojack, no.
That is so degrading.
We've had a lot of incredible
guest stars over the years,
and usually, it just happens
because we write a script,
and we think who would be a
good person for this script?
Like, who would be the funniest person
to be judging this booty
competition reality show?
What if it's Felicity Huffman?
And then, we go to them,
and they usually say yes, which is crazy.
Occasionally, we'll hear something like,
"Oh, this person's a big fan of the show."
And then, we'll keep them in mind
if there's a part for them to play.
We don't usually write
parts for the actors.
The scripts always come first,
and then, we think about,
"Well, who should we get to do this?"
And again, our casting director,
Linda Lamontagne is incredible,
and she just kind of
has an ear to the ground
of who's looking to do animation,
who's looking to do
our show, specifically,
who would be fun and surprising,
and so, we get these lists from her,
and it's like, "Oh my God,
you think they'd say yes?"
Like, "We'll ask them."
And sometimes we ask
them, and they say, "No."
but then, they say, "Yes."
and it's very exciting.
But then, we've had
people come on the show
or people that I've seen
who have been heroes
of mine tell me they're fans of the show.
That completely blows my mind.
Like to have Weird Al Yankovic,
who I like grew up with, come
be a guest star on the show,
and tell me personally that
he really loves the show.
My brain can't process that.
I don't know how to take
that kind of compliment,
and I quickly change the
subject to something else.
- Herb, I said I'm sorry.
- Yeah, and I do not forgive you.
- You know, I think it is
up to the individual viewer
to decide for themselves
if Bojack is forgivable,
or redeemable, or deserving of that.
I personally like to believe
that we are all flawed people,
and we are all deserving of forgiveness,
and redemption, and grace,
but we have to work for it.
We're not owed it.
You know what I mean?
We are worthy of it,
but maybe, deserving is the wrong word,
but it's open to interpretation,
and I grapple with that.
I don't always know myself,
and I think, one of the
joys of making the show
is presenting these questions
and not always having the answers,
and accenting sometimes, when
you don't have the answer,
but you feel like you need an answer,
and you put it in your work,
it feels fake or it feel forced.
And so, a lot of times, you
know, we'll have questions,
or we'll talk about it
in the writer's room,
we'll go back and forth,
and at the end of the day,
if it feels like we don't
have a hard answer to this,
we'll just kind of leave the
audience with the question,
and it's up to them.
- [Bojack] I look back
at that other Bojack
and I think, "Who is that?"
- My favorite reaction to the show
that has happened quite a few times now,
and at first I didn't quite
know what to do with it,
and now when it happens,
I say, "Thank you,"
is when people tell me
that the show has helped them articulate
or identify something about themselves
that they've never been able to recognize
or verbalize before,
that the show has helped
them talk to a therapist,
talk to a loved one, realize a truth
that has always been there,
but they've never quite
had the words for it.
Now, they have something to point to,
and go, "Oh, it's like that."
That was not necessarily
what we set out to do
when we were making the show,
but that feels so much
more rewarding to me,
than when people say,
"It's the funny animals.
"It makes me laugh."
I'm glad the funny animals
make people laugh too,
like that definitely is
something we aim for,
and we're very proud of that, as well,
but I would hope that the
lasting legacy of the show
is that people continue to discover it,
and it continues to
articulate things for them
about feelings they've felt,
or ways in which they've seen the world,
and it allows them to, maybe, get help
that they didn't quite
know how to ask for before.
- Nailed it.